good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club my name is larry
Lippmann I'm the president of the
National Press Club and Washington
correspondent for the palm beach post in
the Cox newspapers bureau I would like
to welcome club members and their guests
in the audience today as well as those
of you watching on c-span or listening
to this program on National Public Radio
today's luncheon is also being webcast
by the Securities and Exchange
Commission at their homepage at WWDC
govt before introducing our head table i
would like to remind our members of some
upcoming speakers on Wednesday May
twelfth here she comes miss america
nicole Johnson will be our speaker on
Thursday May thirteenth comedian George
Carlin will be our luncheon guest and
speaker and on Monday May seventeenth
General Colin Powell will discuss
America's Promise press club members may
access transcripts and audio files of
our luncheons at our website and PC
press 0 RG non-members may purchase
audio and video tapes by calling 1888
343 1940 if you have questions for our
speaker please write them on the cards
provided at your table and pass them up
to me and i will ask as many as time
permits i would now like to introduce
our head table guests and ask them to
stand briefly when their names are
called all of our head table journalists
are members of the National Press Club
please hold your applause until all head
table guests are introduced from your
right Darren Gersh Washington bureau
chief nightly business report Neal
Roland Bloomberg News Jerry I to zag
associate editor Kiplinger Washington
letter Mike mcnamee Business Week
Commissioner Laura Unger guest of our
speaker Annette Nazareth director the
SEC s division of market regulation and
guest of our speaker Richard Walker
director of the SEC s division of
enforcement and guest of our speaker ken
s key chairman of our speakers committee
skipping our speaker for a moment Ellen
Paris freelance business writer and
member the speaker's committee
responsible for organizing today's
luncheon Robert Mary president and
publisher congressional quarterly
Nancy waits reuters/mark Beecham
spokesman for the north american
securities administrators Association
and Jim McTeague Washington editor
Barron's today's luncheon speaker is
Arthur Levitt chairman of the Securities
and Exchange Commission during his
nearly six-year tenure at the head of
the SEC our securities markets have
undergone an historic transformation in
just a few short years we have become a
nation of stockholders today almost half
of all American households have
investments directly or indirectly in
the stock market Wall Street has gone
mainstream which has profound economic
social regulatory and yes political
implications since chairman Levitt took
the helm of the SEC the Dow Jones
Industrial Average has roughly tripled
but I suspect unlike some politicians in
this town he won't try to take credit
for that chairman Levin has been a vocal
and aggressive advocate for the investor
on Main Street among his initiatives he
has led major reforms in the Nasdaq
security stuff Nasdaq stock market
giving investors better prices when they
buy and sell Nasdaq stocks he has urged
the financial industry to use plain
English and its sales literature
disclosure documents he is fought fraud
in the so called micro cap markets as
well as on the internet and he has
dramatically expanded the SEC s investor
education efforts today chairman Lovett
will talk about two forces which are
further transforming and democratizing
Wall Street the internet and new
electronic trading systems thanks to
technology Main Street Americans have
more direct access to the markets and
more control over their investments than
ever before at the same time however
some critics are raising concerns that
these new trading scheme systems may be
encouraging investors to trade too much
and maybe helping to create a culture of
speculation that could be setting up our
markets for a big fall before president
clinton appointed him SEC chairman
Levitt had a long career on Wall Street
from nineteen seventy eight to nineteen
eighty nine he was chairman of the
America
stock exchange and a note to this
audience chairman Levitt used his own
roll call a local newspaper that covers
Capitol Hill he used to own I'm sorry
used to own roll call a local newspaper
the covers capitol hill so he knows a
little bit about the media therefore I
don't need to remind him that his
remarks this afternoon are very much on
the record ladies and gentlemen let's
give a warm National Press Club welcome
to Arthur Levitt
today you can hardly pick up a newspaper
turn on television overhear a
conversation or talk to a friend without
some mention of the internet it's done
nothing short of changing the way the
world works the way our nation invests
and I think overall it's changed us for
the better I'm here today not to
extolled the Internet's virtues I think
they're self-evident or to raise a red
flag of danger instead I want to talk
plainly and sensibly about the
challenges that it presents in the most
practical ways last week I visited
Martin Luther King high school in New
York to talk about the importance of
financial literacy the first question I
got from a young student was how do i
get to invest in one of those internet
stocks we're living in a time when the
stock market is more a part of a
American consciousness than ever before
after years of nothing but up markets
and empowering technology the investor
psyche has gone through a lot of changes
memories of shortened and important
points have gotten forgotten in all the
excitement we as a nation as investors
as businesses and as regulators should
not be manic about the mania as cliche
as it may be fundamentals still apply I
want to review them here whether they
take the form of advice to investors
guidance to brokers or reasoned action
for regulators first to investors I want
to talk about your responsibilities when
investing over the Internet second to
online brokerages in the enthusiasm over
online trading you can never
lose sight of your fundamental
obligation to your customers and third
I'd like to discuss how the SEC is
responding to these changes to protect
investors and to help maintain market
integrity today more than 7 million
Americans trade online accounting for
twenty-five percent of all trades made
by individual investors in 1994 not one
person traded over the internet and in
the next few years the number of online
brokerage accounts will roughly equal
the metropolitan populations of Seattle
San Francisco Denver Boston Dallas Miami
Atlanta Chicago all combined the breadth
and pace of change prompted by the
internet is absolutely phenomenal but
while it changes the way millions of
Americans invest online investing does
not alter the basic framework that has
governed our markets for the past 65
years laws regulating our markets are a
product of the New Deal era to me their
concepts are as indelible as the
Constitution they've weathered challenge
after challenge decade after decade and
are every bit as relevant and effective
today as they were the day they were
written companies offering their shares
weather awful website or by means of a
paper prospectus still have to disclose
what they are selling and why brokers
whether traditional or online still have
the same obligation to their customers
and fraud where the perpetrated over the
internet on the phone or in person is
still fraud consequently
I'm not convinced it's necessary for the
SEC to pronounce a totally new and
radical scheme of regulation
specifically dedicated to online
investing yet I don't rule out the
possibility that there may come a time
when the SEC sees a need for new
approaches to better meet the
imperatives of the Internet what must
occur now is a greater recognition by
investors of their own individual
responsibility I'm talking specifically
about an individual's duty to understand
and control the level of risk that he or
she is assuming that level can vary with
the type of activity and investor
undertakes on one end of the spectrum
lie investors who occasionally trade
online and hold their investments for
the longer term they're basically retail
investors manage their portfolios
through online accounts on the other end
of the spectrum are so-called day
traders whose time horizon for moving in
and out of stock positions is measured
by minutes if not sentence some argue
that day trading is really nothing more
than speculation and speculation is not
new to our markets personally I don't
think day traders are speculating
because speculating requires some market
knowledge they are instead gambling
which really doesn't historically
full-time risk-taking has been an
activity engaged in by a relatively
small number of professional traders I'm
concerned that more and more people may
be undertaking day trading strategies
without a complete understanding of the
risk and difficulty involved no one
should have any illusions of what he's
getting involved in I know of one state
that recently found that 67
out of 68 day traders that a firm had in
fact lost money as somewhere in the
middle of this spectrum with long-term
investors on one side and the short-term
day traders on the other is an
increasing number of Americans who use
their online accounts both to invest
longer-term and a trade short-term on
momentum or small change changes in the
price of a stock I call this kind of
mixed strategy day trading light I'm
concerned about the greater influx of
new and relatively inexperienced
investors who may be so seduced by the
ease and speed of internet trading that
may may be trading in a way that does
not match their specific goals and risk
tolerance in our society a kind of
mythology has grown through books and
movies and television about the power of
the trader and all too many individuals
get behind a computer keyboard and
believe that they can emulate this kind
of machismo that goes with the traitor
when they lack the experience they lack
the temperament and they lack the
resources on the other hand a greater
number of Americans investing for their
futures and helping to raise capital I
think is in the long run good for our
markets and good for our country as far
as I'm concerned for most individuals
the stock market is best used for
investing rather than trading and I
think it's important to make that
distinction online trading may be quick
and easy online investing and I
emphasize investing requires the same
old-fashioned elbow grease like
researching a company or taking the time
to appreciate the level of risk I'm
often surprised by investors who spend
more time deciding what move
l rent then on which stock to buy
regardless of how frequently a person
trades are invests and the opportunity
to make these decisions comes with the
responsibility to take the time to
understand the implications of those
decisions we have noticed for common
misconceptions that investors have about
online trading the first is that
although the internet makes it seem as
if you have a direct connection to the
securities markets you don't when you
push that enter key your order is sent
to your broker who then sends it to the
market to be executed this process is
usually seamless and electronic it is
not however guaranteed lines may clog
systems may break orders may back up
even when automated systems can handle a
lot of investors who want to buy or sell
the same stock at the same time align
forms price quotes are only for a
limited number of shares some investors
may not receive the currently quoted
price and as you would expect the price
of that stock will then go up if there
are more buyers or down if there are
more sellers by the time you get to the
front of the line the price of the stock
may be very very different so how do
investors protect themselves from a
rapid price in the change of the stock
part of the answer is considering the
use of a limit order that's the second
thing every online investor needs to
know a limit order buys or sells a
security at a specific price in other
words the order can be executed only if
the market price has not moved past a
certain level on the other hand a market
order buys or sells the stock at
whatever price the security
is at the time the order reaches the
market so if you place a market order to
buy an IPO stock at nine dollars you
could end up by paying $90 by the time
your order is finally executed this
isn't theoretical more than a few
investors have lost all of their savings
thousands and thousands of dollars
because they fail to use a limit price
now sometimes limit orders may not get
executed in a fast-moving market and
some firms may even charge more for them
but at the very least i'd rather not own
a stock or pay a little bit more upfront
and be totally unprepared or incapable
of paying a heck of a lot more later on
my goals as an investor may be different
than yours but considering the costs and
benefits of limit orders that's part of
your responsibility in investing in
today's market the third misconception
is that an order is cancelled when you
hit the cancel button but the fact is
that it's cancelled only when the market
receives that cancellation you may get
an electronic confirmation but that may
mean only that your request to cancel
was received not that your order was
actually cancelled recently one major
brokerage firm wasn't able to process
twenty percent of the cancellation
orders on a fast moving IPO one investor
placed an online order for two thousand
shares of the stock thought she
cancelled it and then placed another
order for a thousand shares after
realizing that she had two orders
outstanding she tried counseling both
instead she owed her broker over a
quarter million dollars for three
thousand shares after wanting to invest
roughly eighteen thousand dollars most
cases may not be that exceptional but I
urge investors to contact their firm
to see how they can ensure a
cancellation order actually works lastly
if you plan to buy money to buy a stock
you also need to know the terms of the
loan your broker gives you that's called
margin when you buy on margin the price
that you pay represents collateral on
that loan in volatile volatile markets
investors who put up an initial margin
payment for a stock may find themselves
required to provide additional cash if
the price falls some investors have been
shocked to find out that if they don't
meet the margin call the brokerage firm
has a right to sell their securities
without any notification and potentially
at a substantial loss to the investors
others have been surprised to learn that
they are lending to or borrowing from
other customers in their firm who may
have excess balances in their margin
accounts it's clear that if an investor
fails to understand the use and
consequences of margin he does so at his
own peril let me turn briefly to some of
the concerns I have about the role of
online firms firms should remember that
while online trading may play
significantly more responsibility in the
hands of investors it doesn't absolve
firms of their obligations to customers
most firms are doing a pretty good job
especially in the light of dramatic
growth that they are experiencing but as
the internet rapidly becomes more and
more an integral part of investing for
more and more investors I asked
brokerage firms to help protect their
integrity for the long run first they
need to ensure that their ability to
provide effective customer service keeps
pace with their growth if you're
marketing your firm to new customers
you'd better be able to provide them
service when they do business with you
firms are opening and astonishing 15,000
new accounts a day that means
fifteen thousand potential complaints a
day especially if the system goes down
our investors having a hard time getting
their mail answered our customer service
800 numbers constantly busy our
complaints about failures or delays and
order execution account accessibility
and other issues overwhelming the firm's
compliance departments second all firms
with our online discount or full-service
have an obligation to ensure the best
execution the best execution of their
customers orders that's not just good
business practice it's a legal
obligation firms have the same duty to
their customers to find the best prices
whether they charge ten dollars per
trade or a hundred dollars per trade the
Commission has long stressed two firms
the importance of obtaining the best
possible price when they route their
customers orders they simply can't let
payment for order flow or other
relationships determine where they do
business that's why I have directed our
examiner's to focus in on firms order
routing practices in a broad-reaching
examination sweep I urge all firms to
review their practices to ensure that
they're doing right by their customers
third firms need to communicate much
more clearly to investors we reviewed
the disclosure and account agreements
both on paper and on web pages overall
we found that most firms address the
different types of orders available and
fewer firms discuss how market
volatility and the use of margin can
affect online investors and almost none
talk about the risks what to do in the
event of system capacity and outage
problems I know that customer's orders
can be slowed down for reasons that are
beyond two firms control
but explaining clearly to customers
rather than merely disclaiming liability
through complex and legalistic language
would go a long way toward reducing the
complaints pouring into the SEC Congress
and the firm's lastly I worry about how
some online firms advertise quite
frankly some advertisements more closely
resemble commercials for the lottery
than anything else when firms again and
again tell investors that online trading
can make them rich it creates
unrealistic expectations and when firms
so those grandiose and unrealistic
expectations they stand a good chance of
reaping the adverse results when many of
them go unmet now in today's bull market
there may be an increasing population of
tow truck drivers who now on their own
Islands as a result of online investing
assuming there's not I don't rule out
the fact that some of these commercials
are tongue-in-cheek but in a market
environment such as we are experiencing
today I don't accept the notion that
tongue in cheek is all there is to it
because the implications of that kind of
get rich easy whether it has
tongue-in-cheek or not kind of
trivializes a process which is
fundamentally so important and so
serious I recently saw one commercial
which showed two women rushing in from
their job to trade before the market
closed after a few clicks of the mouse
one woman proclaims i just made
seventeen hundred dollars the other one
kind of sheepishly replies by admitting
i invest in mutual funds well what's the
implication of that message has it
become passé to invest for the longer
term and to diversify your risk now some
will argue that we shouldn't tell
terms how to sell lip products as long
as its lawful I agree but selling
securities is not like selling soap
brokers have always had duties to their
customers that go beyond simply buyer
beware and nobody's going to stop me
from giving my own personal feelings
about the kind of advertising that I
think may be cute but is also demeaning
and I'll say that as often as I choose
to that's not regulating advertising
that's my right to express my judgment
my opinion that's talking down to the
American public and I have some
questions about that I've asked the NASD
regulatory unit to hold a roundtable on
advertising to add to the work they're
already doing to improve fairness in
advertising I call on all firms to join
in this effort I've also asked Jay Chou
formerly the head of advertising firm
giant day to work with the NASD and
industry leaders to consider the Public
Interest issues this type of advertising
implicates today I've talked about what
investors need to be aware of if they
invest over the Internet I've also
discussed some of the issues firm should
be addressing as technology recasts our
market and helps attract more and more
investors than ever before the SEC s
mission to protect investors and
maintain market integrity remains
absolute securities fraud perpetrated
over the internet represents a signal
challenge for the SEC while the scans
we've seen on the internet are the same
basic scams that have always accompanied
the flow of money the internet speed low
cost and relative anonymity give con
artists access to an unprecedented
number of innocent in
esther's policing that marketplace will
require more resources more manpower
more money nevertheless we are prepared
to do whatever is necessary to help
protect investors last year we created
the SEC cyber force a specially trained
nationwide core of 125 attorneys
accountants and analysts tasked with the
responsibility of searching for Internet
fraud this year we will increase that
number by 100 percent and for next year
the Commission is asked for an 11
million dollar increase to expand our
efforts to combat fraud second we will
continue to inspect firms offering
online trading we've already conducted
inspections of firms that represent
eighty percent of the market share based
on our initial findings I sent a letter
this morning to all online brokerage
firms requesting that they improve the
quality of their disclosure to investors
when firms achieve the highest quality
of service and continually act in the
interests of their customers they create
a customer for life instead of just
another one time short-term trading
opportunity the SEC and the self
regulating agencies are also inspecting
all of the brokerage firms that
specialize in day trading clearly
providing day trading opportunities is
not itself against the law but these
firms should be on notice but they are
still broker dealers and they must
operate within existing laws that means
complying with disclosure capital margin
and best execution requirements as well
as maintaining updated and comprehensive
books and records and any firm weather
day trading or online that recommends a
type of investment strategy or
customizes in
investment research should ensure that
it's suitable for investors third I'm
announcing today the formation of a
formal SEC private sector Advisory
Committee on technology it will
encompass not only how the Commission
might better leverage its resources to
protect investors and safeguard market
integrity but also examine issues
specifically related to online trading
I've asked General Ken minahan former
head of the National Security Agency who
honors us with his presence this
afternoon and brand ferron a true
innovator and technology to lead this
effort in lending cutting-edge expertise
to the SEC we intend to involve
representatives of all of the
constituents of the Commission to
represent an approach to dealing with
technological issues over the course of
coming months and years fourth the
Commission unveils its new investor
education web page the website is WWE
CEO V it includes detailed information
and tips on online investing how to
detect fraud both on and off the
internet and other important information
on saving and investing in addition in
the letter that I sent to online firms I
have asked them to create links from
their website to the SEC s website I
hope we can all agree that an armful and
informed and knowledgeable investor is
good for the industry and good for
individual businesses lastly I want to
raise some points about chat rooms which
increasingly have become a source of
information and misinformation for many
investors they've been compared to a
kind of high-tech version of morning
gossip or advice at the company water
cooler
at least you know your co-workers at the
water cooler that's just not true on the
internet and i hope that investors
realize that i wonder how many chatroom
participants realize that if someone is
waxing poetic about a certain stock that
person could well be getting paid to do
it for the future of this medium i
encourage investors to take what they
see over chat rooms not with a grain of
salt but with a rock of salt and by
doing so you protect yourself and you
protect the internet I've asked the
major internet providers who host these
trap rooms to place a link to the SEC
website where investors can learn more
about online investing and file a
complaint if necessary I want everyone
in a chatroom know that if someone is
taking advantage of the technology you
have the opportunity to shine a light on
it think of it as kind of a neighborhood
watch on the internet all of us are
participants in an extraordinary
absolutely extraordinary social
phenomena the democratization of our
markets is a desirable development which
regulators should not frustrate our
mission is not to prevent losers or do
modulate that sometimes mercurial
movement of our markets the standards by
which we will determine our methods of
surveillance education market structure
disclosure and if necessary enforcement
will be an unyielding commitment an
unyielding commitment to the well-being
of investors I call on all market
participants the media fellow regulators
and lawmakers to help us fulfill this
commitment by working together to make
the 20
first century defined as much by trust
as technology thank you very much
mr. Chairman I think you committed news
here today my first question is does
what goes up always come down yes so we
can expect a fall eventually is the
press you mentioned the media is the
press demonstrating sufficient
confidence to uncovering these issues at
the SEC for full public understanding
the American public today is better
informed better educated better able to
make decisions than any time in history
and I think that is largely due to the
competence of the press and their
relentless search for news that remains
beneath the news this is a new
development a new technology a lots
going on mistakes will be made and have
been made but I do think that the press
is doing quite a good job of it why
should we care about day traders that
they want to risk their money in silly
ways whose problem is it but their own I
think that's basically so I'm not saying
that we should have any particular care
for day traders they represent a
relatively small slice of the market
they add liquidity to the market I don't
propose regulating day traders what I do
propose is if the people promoting day
trading are promoting unrealistic
expectations if they are using
fraudulent means of enlisting day
traders if they are misusing margin
requirements that's where the Commission
has a responsibility to step in what I
intend to accomplish in this
presentation and others like it all
around the country is to just put on
notice people that are considering this
that markets by definition have levels
of volatility and
and there is no such thing in my
judgment in my experience as an easy
buck and I am not proposing any
regulation of day traders you mentioned
fraud on the internet given the size
global scope and growth of the net is it
beyond policing nothing is beyond
policing and yet nothing is susceptible
to a total response by regulators there
simply is no agency which has the
resources the skills the people power to
eliminate all graft and misdeeds and
fraud but by being pointed as this
commission has been with respect to
areas of concern such as fraudin some of
our municipal markets such as prime bank
fraud such as the other areas that we
have been concerned with and by
targeting our response as we have with
respect to accounting frauds we intend
to highlight those areas that investors
must be careful of and one that
obviously we're going to devote more
resources to than ever before as
demonstrated by our doubling of the size
of our cyber force is that area will we
be able to eliminate it all absolutely
not but we will be able to engage a
partnership hopefully with the public
and the media so that we are better able
as a country and investors to protect
ourselves the states have been active in
day trading and online trading issues
the brokerage industry however has asked
Congress to reduce the state's authority
to license and regulate stock brokers
what do you think is this a good idea I
think to adequately protect the American
public requires a partnership among
regulators requires a partnership
between self regulatory agencies the
regulator's themselves private rights of
action and the states that partnership
is terribly important it has stood us in
good stead and I would not do violence
to any element of it you're to
nationwide internet sweeps have resulted
in action against only in a zoom this is
correct 47 people so when you talk of
internet fraud being such a big problem
are you exaggerating I think not I don't
think you can measure fraud by the
number of cases that the Commission
brings we bring approximately 400 cases
a year i think it's the quality of the
case that's brought that really matters
the fact that we're bringing that we
have brought 40 cases matched against
perhaps no cases the year before
indicates that this is an important
direction for us and i think as far as
the future i signal today that this is a
major focal point for the commission
where we are going to expend more of our
resources more of our focus so this is
not a numbers game this is a targeted
effort businessweek recently alleged
price fixing and collusion by brokers on
the American Stock Exchange similar to
what you went after on NASDAQ what can
you say to reassure investors that
they're getting a fair shake I don't
know that those the problems alleged by
Business Week with respect to the amex
are comparable to those that call for
Commission action with respect to nasdaq
i think that if you examine the cases
that the Commission has brought dealing
both with fraudsters and dealing as well
with those self-regulating organizations
that have not fulfilled their mandate to
protect the public you'll see that we've
been fairly broad reaching in terms of
the scope of what we've done is any
progress being made toward the
development of internationally
recognized accounting standards that
would enable foreign companies to list
their stock on the New York Stock
Exchange I think considerable progress
has been made as you know the
International Accounting Standards
Commission has been hard at work for
several years now trying to harmonize
Internet
national standards with us domestic
standards we've been an active
participant in that process and there's
been greater progress made than I would
have expected a few years ago indeed we
have agreed to accept a number of
provisions that in some cases are better
than us standards in other cases are
just as rigorous and that's the basic
requirement that the Commission is made
that whatever international standards
developed give international investors
the same basic protections that US
investors have with us death at the end
of the day and the report of this is
going to come out over the course of
coming weeks I suspect that while we
will agree to many of those standards
there'll be some that fall short so this
is working progress and the Commission
intends to issue a concept release
letting the public and commentators know
what standards have been proposed and at
the end of that period of time we'll be
able to make some decisions in terms of
international standards in other words
my long-winded answer to your question
is progress has been made there will not
be a time certain over the next several
months where we will be able to say we
have international standards let's move
on from there to what do you attribute
the forenzian and trading in internet
related stocks I think attendant upon
markets which have experienced the kind
of one-way action that our markets have
for a number of years suggest that many
investors have become emotional rather
than intellectual about making
investments whether you call at a frenzy
or the kind of natural market
fluctuation that is attendant upon an
economy which is operated as
successfully as ours with productivity
reaching a point that very few would
have certainly very few economists would
have predicted as recently as several
years ago I don't think that's abnormal
well following up on that Alan Greenspan
once used the term irrational exuberance
to describe the boom market do you think
the market exuberance of today is
rational I must relate to you a brief
story I met Alan a few months ago at the
Kennedy Center and said how are you Alan
he looked at me carefully and scrutiny
and said I'm not allowed to say but what
about the exuberance let me let you off
that easy yes the market is exuberant
think that for what it's worth how do
you feel about investing social security
in the stock market I speak as an
individual not on behalf of a commission
I think that investing some of the
Social Security funds in equities is
something that this country's
policymakers should seriously consider I
believe that there are some caveats that
go with that the most important of which
is educating investors so that if they
are faced with a number of choices and I
would hope that those choices would be
limited choices they would be in a
better position to make those choices
than I believe some investors are able
to make today but i think that the
notion of doing that is something that i
personally think is is worth considering
there were published reports today that
NASDAQ and AMEX are considering an IPO
you have to know the lingo here what is
the SCC's position on that possibility I
don't know what the se sees position
would be on that possibility but having
run a self-regulating organization and
having been personally frustrated by the
kind of governance that those
institutions involved it's almost like
if you had a huge partnership of a
thousand people and you had to reconcile
all those views making decisions and
responding to change becomes very very
difficult so if I was head of the
American Stock Exchange today or the
head of any SRO and somebody said you
boy you could change this into a
corporate structure I would wax
enthusiastic about I'd want to know how
soon you've told the corporate bond
dealers their prices aren't transparent
enough and that their first attempt at
providing some prices through go fix
isn't sufficient how hard are you going
to push this and why I'm going to push
it very hard because I believe that our
debt markets while they are not as
liquid as our equity markets certainly
should be as transparent and we've come
a long way certainly our municipal
markets today are much more transparent
than ever before and since so much of
the ownership of debt is going into
public hands I regard this as a terribly
important initiative what we're talking
about is a cultural change where dealers
in these markets have been used to
dealer markets rather than retail
markets low I think we've got to adjust
I think that the interests of the retail
investor are so important in this regard
and they're the amount of dollars
involved either through funds or
individual investment is so important
that we intend to try to catalyze the
process and working with the industry
try to get greater transparency as
quickly as we possibly can today the
Senate began consideration of the
financial service the modernization bill
what is the SEC position on the bill and
why the bill that was reported out of
the house Banking Committee
and that is working its way through the
Senate Banking Committee is one that in
its present form this commission simply
this member of the Commission at lease
imp leak a not support I believe that in
its present form it is hurtful to
investors that it does not allow the
kinds of protections that I think a bill
should have in terms of consistent
regulation and tend to testify on this
tomorrow but I will say at that time
that I have great reservations about the
implications of this bill to the
interests of America's investors could
you tell us how you think the bill could
be strengthened I think the bill could
be strengthened by eliminating some of
the arcane exemptions that exist in the
bill permitting banks in effect as we
interpret the bill to regulate products
that are essentially securities products
ranging from mutual fund sold by banks
to the trust fund exemption which would
allow as we read it even a large
brokerage firm to be conducted within a
banks trust apartment without running
afoul of the law so those exemptions
have to be eliminated or change
dramatically to see to it that
consistent regulation sees to it that
securities activities within a bank are
regulated by securities regulators and
that securities regulators have the
ability to go right up into the bank and
see to it that and be able to inspect
the bank's role as advisors to mutual
funds if that is the case
what if anything is the SEC doing about
quote front-running by various new
sources and insiders insider trading is
probably greater today than at any time
since the 80s it's not readily trans not
readily apparent because we haven't had
many cases of people running around with
bags full of cash but it's there and
we're bringing more cases than we
brought then in those cases where we see
fraud by news sources we are bringing
cases in those instances as well have
you decided yet what's a dual about
analysts you doubt their objective ities
are correct no I don't doubt the
objectivity of analysts I think the
analysts today are in America are better
provide a better service than any
analyst group that I can ever recall in
the history of the securities business
what I am concerned about is the
perceived and I suspect sometimes real
conflicts of interests that go on within
firms where analysts are commenting on
companies that have other relationships
with the sponsoring firm the firm that
provides investment banking services the
firm that provides guidance of one kind
or another counseling valuations and
sales of that particular Enterprise some
firms have pretty good firewalls in that
regard others do not I am suggesting
that we're going to take a hard and
serious look at this practice because
I'd rather be there before it happens
then to have to be responsive to a
problem that develops afterward and
I think this is something that the
firm's have to think carefully about I
know that those firewalls have been
erected but markets change competition
moves us to do things we might not
otherwise do and I think in this arena
we've got to look a fresh at problems of
this kind almost on a week by week basis
we've got two questions about the year
2000 basically how concern to you about
the markets that were markets will
respond to the year 2000 problem
securities firms have done a lot of
testing what about linkages with futures
exchanges and brokers in the US and
overseas any concerned about too much
trading or too little as January first
approaches I think our markets are fully
able to handle capacity issues as far as
the ability of America's markets to
respond to the year 2000 problem they
are going to be ready to meet that issue
yes there may be a few outline firms
that have some problems but the industry
as a whole I believe is in first great
shape and I do not expect any
significant problems now with respect to
global transactions I have no question
but that international institutions
whether they be financial or otherwise
are not nearly as ready for the year
2000 as we are what has to be done is to
determine what the response will be to
counter parties and I think the firms
are thinking very hard about that and we
are working very closely with the firm's
I think what's important is that all of
us develop contingency plans we've been
testing and retesting the systems and we
will continue to do that we're in the
process of developing contingency plans
but I'm quite sanguine about the ability
of the industry to respond I think the
greatest danger that the country faces
from the year 2000 problem as a country
is the attitude of our citizens and the
securities business and outside of that
if we get panicked and we begin to hoard
or we cancel reservations on airline so
we do all the things that people do out
of a sense of panic we will bring about
the very result that we're trying to
avoid have enough confidence in the
American people to believe that if we
can satisfy them in terms of the
specifics of what's being done and the
money that's being spent that's not
going to happen chairman i want to thank
you for coming today and present you
with this certificate of appreciation
suitable for framing and the much valued
National Press Club coffee mug I'm still
trying to find out just how valuable it
is because we're putting something on
ebay com to find auction it off see how
how valuable it is why our last question
is a few of us lived through the stock
market crash of 1929 could it happen
again sure and what are you doing about
it again i would say that our markets
have weathered every kind of domestic
and international catastrophe and
weathered them well we had the drop of
87
we've had all kinds of market events
like that we'll have them in the future
of different I've found that no two
market events are precisely alike and
the next market event which we are
preparing to protect ourselves against
the last market event will be totally
different but the systems have greater
resourcefulness greater resiliency
greater backup greater contingency plans
than ever before and I'm confident in
our ability to withstand any kind of
market event that the country is seen in
the past or I expect to see in the
future thank you very much
German limit thank you for coming today
I would also like to thank national
press club staff members Leanne borin
Pat Nelson Melanie abdo de menthe and
Howard Rothman for organizing today's
lunch also thanks to the National Press
Club library for their research were
adjourned mr. chairman here is your